okay so this question asks how do you
keep all the secrets of the book to come
to yourself are you dying to tell people
what you know or do a few people already
know everything
um
i'm not dying to tell everyone what i
know i i eventually i will have to yield
up all my secrets but uh
actually if anything maybe i hold on to
some of these things too long i don't
know there's always the question you
know when do you reveal something do you
how long do you draw it out and
you know the books are full of little
puzzles and enigmas and uh reversals and
you know how do you how do you place
those uh you don't want to give it away
too soon but if you stretch it out too
long everybody's going to guess it
anyway so
you know at what point is is that but
i kind of like
having the puzzles and you need to keep
at least some of the puzzles to the end
so
uh but then again you can't you can't
keep them all to the end otherwise you
you end with a final chapter that's
just you know one guy endlessly talking
about well there's this and then there's
this and the explanation for this is
this and it's a very boring and not very
good chapter
so uh
um
david and dan know a few things a few
important revelations so
um
eventually if i am you know hit by a
truck or something like that they would
know a few things but they don't know
all by any means and my editors know a
few things and have guessed a few things
uh i suspect that some of the fans
probably know more than anything else i
mean i'm going to be doing the
concordance the ice and fire concordance
is the next project the world of ice and
fire which is under contract to bantam
and random house and i'm doing that with
elio garcia and linda ann thompson of
the westeros site and
i swear they know westeros better than i
do i mean the elio's knowledge of it is
just absolutely amazing you know i
when i'm writing books i sometimes you
know call him up and say i'm about to
introduce this character i think i
mentioned him in book three did i ever
say what color his eyes are and you know
within a half hour i get you know blue
gray page 314 second book
oh very good so
great i hate eye colors everybody should
have the same color eyes i'm kind of
i'm constantly getting screwed up on eye
colors
just make them all purple yeah